there's a great Family Guy clip where
there's a transvestite sitting at a bar
and the transvestite is looking at
pornography on his phone and the
bartender comes over and says ma'am you
can't look at pornography at this bar
and the transvestite says no no it's
okay I'm transgender and the bartender
says oh I'm sorry I didn't realize that
okay do whatever you want whenever you
want to do it and that is very much what
seems to occur in our culture whether
we're talking at a bar or in public or
even at schools and one mother has had
enough of it one mother an absolute hero
mom showed up to a school board meeting
wearing frankly a shocking scandalous
completely inappropriate outfit to the
meeting it just so happens that it was
the same outfit that had been worn by a
drag queen at the kids school that very
year and so why is it that a giant
hulking dude can wear a silly leotard
but mother cannot why is it
inappropriate for for a woman to wear
the woman's clothing and not for the man
School Board didn't seem to have much of
an answer that mother is Kimberly reichs
a stay-at-home mother of seven children
we call that a small Catholic Family
Kimberly thank you for coming on the
show
thank you so much for having me on
Michael I am I'm honored to be on your
show I am so pleased to hear that and I
absolutely adored your stunt what was
the reaction in the room
um Mal's dropped to the floor and there
was one lady in particular sitting
behind me just making snood remarks like
I can't believe she's in that ew put
some clothes on I'm like yeah and that's
when I turned around and addressed her
actually and said yeah if this ticks you
off then it should because this guy came
into our school dressed like this and
that seemed to be okay
so this makes your head spin this pisses
you off in any way shape or form it
should because I'm embarrassed to stand
here in the outfit that I am today but I
have a point to prove and that is that
this outfit should not be ever accepted
in our schools by the way it's it's not
even just what's good for the goose is
good for the gander because you are a
very nice looking lady you still
probably shouldn't wear those things at
school but it makes more sense for a
very nice looking lady to wear ladies
clothing makes a whole lot less sense
for a big hulking dude to wear that
clothing so it's actually much more
inappropriate much more grotesque for
the guy to do it can you explain what
actually happened to prompt your your
appearance at the school board so what
happened was that back in May when I
exposed the drag queen show for what it
was and asked our school board then like
why did this happen how did this get
into our schools what are you planning
on doing to ensure it doesn't happen
again they fought out ignored me they
brushed me under the rug they tried to
censor me and I was not gonna have it
and me along with hundreds of parents
here in Ankeny Iowa we're wanting to
know a hundred and some odd days later
now and 40 days entered the school year
why have we not heard the investigation
results of that GSA program who let him
in why was it allowed and why didn't
that guy not get a background check I
can't go eat lunch with my kids let
alone walk into a school half dressed
and perform for them so what's good for
them is not good for me
you mentioned the GSA which stands for
the gay straight Alliance it's one of
these LGBT clubs in the schools and you
mentioned this drag show and I get that
there are more questions probably than
answers but what actually happened with
the club and the drag queen
so the GSA
um hired this guy to come in to perform
for the children
um as young as 12. he was a 21 year old
male exotic dancer he does not attend
the school he never attended the school
and for him to come in to perform for
our children was just outstanding and
like why what was the purpose of that
and so that's questions that we still
have no answers to how old are the kids
in this club
the youngest one that attended the show
was 12.
it's sick that is absolutely sick I I
assume the club has a faculty advisor is
that right
yes they are supposed to so the GSA is a
school
um credited but not funded
um program it's funded actually by the
CDC and there's teachers that overlook
this GSA program that is supposed to be
monitoring it and so there was two
teachers in particular that are still
teachers there in Ankeny school today
the one is the choir teacher and there's
one that is a um I believe she's an
English teacher and as far as we know
there's no there's been no repercussions
on what they did and why they allowed
this to happen in our schools you were
about to make me feel better when you
said yes the school has given
accreditation to this club but they
don't give the club any money until you
told me that the club is funded by the
federal government that actually makes
me feel a lot worse uh but okay I'm not
going to blame a 12 year old for making
a a stupid choice and inviting a drag
queen into a club 12 year olds make
stupid decisions all the time that's
pretty much the definition of being a 12
year old but you're telling me there are
two faculty advisors here so then my
question is one did they know what what
did they know and when did they know it
and two if they did not know then what
kind of negligence is that for a club
advisor
oh they knew for sure because they posed
in front of
um on the stage at the end there was a
huge photo at the end of the stage that
showed all the teachers happily standing
there
with all the students that performed in
that drag queen show and who attended so
that without question the teachers need
to be fired I I would imagine really I
have and you and the parent the other
parents have asked for this
yes we have we have demanded it and they
refuse to do it have you been able to
speak to any political leaders right now
I mean I'm pleased that you can come on
my show we'll spread this as far and
wide as we can it's a national program
we have international listeners so I I
think absolutely that people who are
listening right now should call in and
put a lot of public pressure on to get
these teachers fired get this club shut
down and keep the transvestites out of
the 12 year olds classrooms but has
anyone spoken to uh you know your member
of Congress Senators that no one is
speaking up against this who's actually
in elected office
no but I did have five State reps they
call me or text me saying that they were
proud of what I did and they hope that I
come up to the Capitol this session and
start protesting
um to help get them to get a law passed
so this doesn't happen any further how
long do you think this has been going on
at your kid's school
um I'm guessing at least two years since
Cove has started and that's just being
bringing to light because a lot of this
stuff we saw online and so a lot of the
kids are more open about talking about
it and so I don't think if without covid
we would have seen it as quickly but
since with coven and since we had to go
to like online stuff when the lockdowns
were in price that's when we started
realizing this agenda that they are
pushing on our children
what is so spooky to me is that you're
not in New York you're not in California
you're not in Chicago or Washington DC
you're in Iowa are do you just happen to
be in an extremely radical left-wing
town or County
unfortunately yes I'm in one of the
liberalist towns in Ankeny but that's
okay because last session we actually
got
um the town flipped from Blue to Red we
ended up getting six seats overturned in
our city we had three students three um
school board members overturned one city
mayor and two city councilmen so we do
have more of a conservative
um running now but it's they have a huge
mess to clean up and I think that
they're just getting buried left and
right and I have to imagine no matter
how left-wing the town is I mean
obviously it can't be all that left wing
if if the political Tides have shifted
so much but no matter how left-wing your
neighbors are
I think if you did a public opinion poll
of your neighbors I can't imagine that
most of them are going to support drag
shows for 12 year olds right am I am I
am I giving too much credit to to your
county no there's very small amount of
them that will actually want that in our
County there most people do not want it
but most people it gets hidden from so
like the GSA program was not made public
that this was going to happen it was not
made known to all students it was in it
was basically exclusive for those
students in the GSA and it did happen
after hours but then that just means us
more questions it just makes us ask how
did they get um into the school building
after hours who let them in who who
approved all this because there's
protocols that you have to go through in
order to be able to host any kind of
show in the in the school and the
administration of this of the particular
school has to sign off you have to have
the approval of the super intended and
none of that happened here and it all
just got brushed under the rug like why
why is that okay
[Music]